if you or someone you know has recently
had a coronary artery bypass graft or
cabbage this video will help you
understand the steps of the procedure
and how it restores blood flow to your
heart
a coronary artery bypass graft or
cabbage is performed to improve
circulation to the heart muscle
in this procedure a healthy artery or
Vein from another part of the body is
connected or grafted to the blocked
coronary artery
the grafted artery or vein bypasses the
blocked portion of the coronary artery
carrying oxygen-rich blood to the heart
muscle
one or more coronary arteries may be
bypassed during a single operation
before the surgery an intravenous line
will be started and you may be given a
medication to help you relax
cabbage procedures are done under
general anesthesia which will put you to
sleep for the duration of the operation
a breathing tube will be inserted
through your mouth and into your throat
to help you breathe
a catheter will be placed in your
bladder to drain your urine
coronary artery bypass surgery generally
takes three to six hours
during a conventional bypass surgery
your surgeon Begins by making an
incision in the skin over your
breastbone or sternum
he or she will then cut the sternum and
move your rib cage in order to get to
your heart
throughout the procedure your
circulatory system may be connected to a
cardiopulmonary bypass pump or heart
lung machine
this machine May temporarily perform the
functions of your heart and lungs during
the surgery
allowing your heart to be stopped if
desired while the surgeon sews the
grafts into place
different blood vessels May typically be
used for The graft the internal thoracic
arteries in the chest also known as
internal mammary arteries or the
saphenous veins in the legs
for the internal thoracic artery graft
your surgeon will leave the upper end
attached to the subclavian artery
and divert the lower end from your chest
wall to your coronary artery just beyond
the blockage
your surgeon will then sew The graft
into place
for the saphenous vein graft your
surgeon will suture one end to the aorta
and the other end to the narrowed artery
just beyond the blockage
with the graft securely in place your
surgeon may use electrical signals to
restore the heartbeat and attach a
temporary pacemaker to the heart
once your heart is again beating
normally if the surgeon used the heart
lung machine it would be disconnected
your surgeon will wire the breastbone
back together and suture the skin
incision closed
a temporary drainage tube will be placed
through the skin beneath the incision
when the surgeon chooses to do the
surgery without using the heart lung
machine the heart continues to beat this
may be referred to as off pump bypass
surgery or minimally invasive surgery
instead a mechanical device is used to
steady the part of the heart where the
grafting is being done
surgeons perform minimally invasive
bypass procedures using specially
designed instruments inserted through
small incisions or ports in the chest
after surgery you will be taken to the
Intensive Care Unit the activity of your
heart will be carefully monitored if
necessary pacing wires will be used to
temporarily control your heart rate
the chest tube will remain in place to
drain excess blood and air from the
chest cavity
once you can breathe on your own your
breathing tube will be removed and
replaced with an oxygen mask the bladder
catheter will remain in place
as you recover from surgery over the
next three to five days all of these
devices will be gradually removed
upon discharge from your procedure be
sure to contact your doctor if you have
any questions or experience any side
effects from the medications you're
taking